Tonight we code in Python.
Hello world.
It's a Raj and what is the best programming language to learn for machine
learning?
There are a lot of options out there and it can be kind of confusing to pick
one.
While it seems beneficial to learn multiple languages since they all have their
unique features,
it's important to avoid overwhelming yourself by picking just one to start.
Machine learning has been around for decades now and more and more companies are
adopting machine learning techniques to improve their products and services
every day.
Some unsuccessfully like apple and with this rise in popularity,
almost every programming language is adding their support for machine learning
algorithms,
but one in particular stands above the rest.
Back in 91 when Guido van Rossum open sourced his side project language,
he called Python,
he likely didn't think that it would be the worlds fastest growing programming
language two decades later.
If we look at stack overflow traffic in terms of the questions that are asked
for specific languages,
it's clear python now has the lead and if we project into the future,
that lead increases by a bigger margin.
The reason for this is that python was built for readability and ease of use.
It's based on the concept of object oriented programming,
but can be used for simple scripting.
It's a great language for a beginner to get started with.
Keywords aren't filled with jargon and often use plain English to describe
concepts.
Most machines come pre installed with it and we can even run python code
directly from the command line or terminal using the built in compiler.
Think about all the incredibly rich fascinating concepts that machine learning
literature is full of like attention mechanisms or multiagent cooperative
systems or Drake a dancing AI.
These are nontrivial concepts that require a grasp of linear Algebra,
calculus,
and probability theory to understand fully and because these concepts require
some time to learn,
it's best if the language involved is relatively simple to learn.
Python,
let's data scientists focus on the complexity that matters.
The Algorithm,
not the syntax,
and python at this point has a package to deal with pretty much any machine
learning task you can think of wanting to do computer vision.
There's open CV.
How about text and Ltk data?
Preprocessing pandas,
general purpose machine learning,
so I get learn tensorflow and the newly christened Pi Torch of course Web Apps,
Djengo data visualization map,
plot line and these are just a few.
These packages offer a very small learning curve in a Jupiter notebook made
originally for python.
You can see the results for each line of code in real time and if you don't want
to use these libraries you can use the matrix math library,
num Pi to build any machine learning algorithm you'd like from scratch with just
some minor changes to the source code.
Python can run on lots of different types of operating systems and environments.
It's got an amazing developer community as well,
whether it's on stack overflow or get hub,
there is free support available for those who ask.
Best of all it's production ready.
Facebook,
the world's largest social network uses python for 21% of its code base and
while it might be a slight pain to upgrade code from python two to python three
it's totally worth it for the other benefits the language provides.
Now,
like I said,
there are a lot of programming languages for machine learning out there,
but if I were to pick a second choice after python,
and this might be controversial to some for me to say,
I'd say it's Javascript,
love it or hate it.
Javascript is the language of the web and it has one of the widest install bases
of any language or framework.
Pretty much any modern personal computing device has a web browser installed,
be that an older smartphone or a super computer.
That fact alone means that machine learning in the browser can serve all of
those devices.
JS is evolving at a rapid speed often in domains nobody would have thought a
couple of years ago from embedded systems to of course machine learning and it's
not all about web development to anymore.
Recently Google released tensorflow dot.
JS which is just one of several examples of a machine learning framework in Java
script that utilizes client side machine learning.
That means that the algorithm can be run directly on the user's device without
needing to talk to a server.
So applications like recommender systems can serve you options,
whether you are at home on the go or completely disconnected from the Internet.
It uses the web GL library to help train models in the browser which uses the
CPU or Gpu of the client device to accelerate matrix math executions.
The number of javascript libraries for machine learning is increasing and a look
at get hub activity helps us confirm that.
Of course javascript has its own equivalents to all the python machine learning
libraries I've mentioned as well as its own popular web development libraries
like you react and angular development is moving fast for all of these.
Okay.
I do have to do a special shout out to both c plus plus and Kuda tensorflow.
The most popular machine learning library currently has a great python
framework,
but for the most part the core isn't actually written in python.
It's a combination of super optimized c plus plus and Kuda,
which is Nvidia's language for programming Gpu.
They used the Eigen,
high performance c plus plus and Kuda numerical library and and videos see you
Dnn library which offers GPU optimized functions like convolutions to help build
the framework.
When we write out a model in tensorflow using python and hit run,
what's actually created is a data flow graph that says to take particular
inputs,
apply particular operations to them and supply the results as input to other
operations all executed by fast c plus plus code.
Both languages aren't nontrivial to learn but have a lot of low level libraries
that help optimize speed immensely.
If you'd like to work on the infrastructure side of things,
c plus plus and Kuta would be great languages to learn.
So those are the most important languages in machine learning currently.
But I also want to say that Matlab is closed source plus expensive and our is
slower than python.
Neither is a good choice at all in terms of learning resources for python.
I've got a great playlist right here on Youtube called learn python for data
science and the book learn python the hard way.
Has a bunch of great examples to help you get started for Javascript,
the tensorflow.
Dot.
Js Docs both on their website and on good hub offer some amazing examples to get
started.
Learning how javascript can be used to train and test ml models linked to
everything will be in the video description.
Hi,
did you like the video?
If you did,
hit the subscribe button and comment down below.
What's your favorite programming language for now?
I've got to engage my wizards,
so thanks for watching.